hey guys I've been meaning to make a
video on make files for a really long
time in fact I did a couple and I just
wasn't happy with them so I'm gonna
attempt a more simple version rather
than have a bunch of scattered duplicate
videos I'm just gonna have like one
series and this is the start of it if if
you like read and stuff learn better
that way
just just Google can you make and RTFM
you know are TFM but if you're not that
RTFM guy
then I'm gonna show you a little just a
little how to example very simple thing
you can do with it the main function of
it what this is gonna be based on it's
gonna be the stuff I was expected to
know for projects just going to college
for computer science so the extreme
basics I've went a lot further on my own
RTFM in but okay so what we're gonna do
here is a quick little project and I'm
gonna show you how make works to handle
building it and running test cases here
we go
can you guys see this oh you can't
answer me because I'm recording this not
live I do stream to and it's very
awkward over there please go check it
out twitch.tv slash bite / oh one seven
one two four catch the awkwardness of me
coding live or whatever the [ __ ] I'm
doing
go get twitch.tv / bipro one seven one
two four I'm just gonna cut this whole
thing of me coding basically okay so
we've made a stupid little program it
doesn't really do anything but it takes
it needs two files so that way I can
show you that so how do you compile this
with make file reliably every time well
let's see how do we use make files
basically you do something and a
semicolon any at the top of the file or
anywhere people usually do this after
the macros and this does it doesn't
matter what the name of this is the very
top one is the default one lot of people
just conformed to call in a default or
all I personally prefer I think default
but sometimes I change that but you
could literally just call it like this
and it's probably legal so fYI that
definitely produced a legal variable
name it's just the top one it's the
default one the rest down here do matter
though and you call them specifically by
name like I'll have one called run maybe
the new line you want to tap over to
start it's command anything to the right
of this semicolon is called a dependency
it's what this relies on to compile or
run so what it does is when you call one
of these commands would make it runs all
the dependencies for example this is
going to rely this main one is going to
be my compiler I hadn't called default
and it's gonna rely on main dot IO and
stuff dardo which is a compiled versions
of these so anytime I just do a plane
make here it'll call that top one and it
has an error oh it actually tried to do
it compile an automatic thing that's
pretty impressive oh I just have this
wrong okay this is another really cool
thing about make files that I didn't
even think of it automatically knows how
to do the basics so if you do this it's
gonna look for these two files and just
like automatically figure it out as you
can see it does but it only goes so far
let's try it let's see what happens yeah
does it mix the two datos but I don't
have a command written down here but it
knows how to handle these dependent
dependencies for C++ innately
which is kind of cool as you can see it
just compiles them it turns them in
objects but how do we run those we don't
have our final run I mean you take those
objects and put them together as you
probably know the C++ but this uses the
basic dependency chain to take care of
things is what make files do so you have
a command you have the stuff it depends
on which will be built if needed and and
these go off the time stamps of the cpp
for them let's go ahead and handle those
objects and compile them so of course
we'll do G plus plus
and we want to compile or two objects to
the main dot o stuff dot o and we're
gonna out the object for this we'll just
call it out and I think on Sigma that's
gonna put a dot exe on it automatically
unless it'll be something else and so
yeah this will handle those two objects
put them together and make a new
executable let's see if that works
first we're gonna let's try to make
clean let's see if it knows make clean
nope so cleans a common rule that people
add kind of jumping around here but
basically what you want to do is to get
rid of all your objects and so to do
that what we do is we do an RM command
for remove what do we want to remove
anything any dot o files
so we'll do start dot out star being the
Reg regular expression for anything and
then the dot out so it'll match all
those object files and it will just
delete them I'm not going to put any
flags on remove but if you want to you
can a lot of people like cursive force
bows you know right now doesn't matter
there's also going to be an out file
which will be a star exe in my case here
so that'll work
or I could also just say out dot star or
something like that whatever regular
expression whatever way you want to
match it to remove this finding now when
we do make clean it'll hit that rule and
run that command in bash which is just
gonna delete police runs this fails on
that one because there's no file or
directory name to hide whatever but it
got rid of the other two just fine okay
let's do a full build now the default
option would just make and there it goes
and we can now run our dot out
of course a dot slash and out and it
does tomato there's an exe Ella use LS
to see that directly and see it there
most terminal support pressing tab to
autofill Steph why I so you can do that
save some time and there it is it runs
and runs fine
so we make cleanup resets everything
there's no longer out file and that's a
very very basic way to get anything
compiling I think that covers the main
basics these main dot this main dot I
own steps Auto as you can see as I said
earlier it implicitly understands how to
build them just because make has that
program nd is it such a common thing but
you can specify them very you know on
your own maybe you have some flags or
something you can say ok this main dot
IO object what we want to do with it
well first of all relies on main dot cpp
or its dependencies main dot cpp now
dependency let me let me explain
dependency a little further just so it's
very clear the dependency if it doesn't
exist within wherever it's looking
forward like in your directory it
executes the command for it execute
smake whatever the name of it is and so
what x it would at this point right here
in the program it would jump down here
run this and do whatever it requires
which as you can see built previously
and just knew how to handle but now
we're gonna make it spelled out because
maybe we want to do something different
- see - main oh and then it sees so
that's the default command but maybe we
want to put Pilar flags on this
my optimization level - or warning all
now when we compile this let's just make
as you can see it took over that and
didn't do the default and ate one and
used ours instead so you can do the same
thing with stuff because it'll hit that
next right now it's just use under
default one which works in this case but
if you want to add your own stuff there
you go now you can do anything else here
I usually like to have a run that just
executes the program
so we how about exe that's always handy
way you just do this usually what I have
to make run do it as well just do
several things in a row first of all
let's see I want to do this simply I
want to have this rely on out althought
exe am I thinking about this right no
cuz you see another thing is it only
runs this command if this if the things
in this dependency list either needed to
be built or needed to be updated so it
keeps track of time stamps and if
anything has a newer time stamp than it
did previously it considers that it
needs to redo the command so if this has
a new time stamp it will rebuild it this
has a new time stamp it will rebuild it
so anytime you update main.cpp
its gonna rebuild this and rebuild this
but it won't rebuild and the stuff does
EVP unless or they get stuffed Auto and
I say it was also updated it will just
keep the old one if it's still the same
so it's smart about handling your the
processing power about what needs to be
built and the whole point of make clean
is maybe maybe it doesn't realize some
stuff needs to be rebuilt so you can do
a make clean and the reset everything
basically and since they don't exist
to rebuild everything after I make clean
sometimes you have to do that after
updating a header if you don't have the
header included in here but what most
people do is they include the header and
a dependency list too so that if it got
updated it'll still build the stuffed
auto again
and same command here so that's another
reason to overwrite these is to include
the header too of course it's going to
be stopped by main there we go
okay well this run so type run I wanted
to go ahead and run the default command
so we do Plus this just makes it run
default I think that's right well
basically you can call other ones of
these directly I'm not gonna do that
instead I'm just gonna say depends on
these to rebuild and then after it's
done rebuilding it runs the execute
command right away so these will go in
order so how'd you make run it rebuilds
it and then executes the command so
using a make file marking it up to how
you're how you want your program to
handle things and test cases oh yeah
another great thing you'll start doing
as I started doing test cases in here
too
the options are endless anything you run
and bash you can put in here so I will
do a follow-up video a part two if you
will hopefully very soon and I'll start
getting into some more advanced things
just take it piece by piece I hope you
understand this video please leave me
some feedback down below leave me some
feedback anything you know whatever you
think could be clearer
any questions maybe you just want to
chat maybe you want to maybe you want to
brag you know I don't care any kind of
comment activity I'm gonna love because
you know new here thanks for supporting
this channel by watching this video I'll
see you next time peace out and good
luck with your make files